well so here's the question
the overlap between owls and death right
so
people it is very common for people to
to report owls either
most often after someone dies and i've
got
so many accounts like this can i tell a
personal story this has like happened to
me
yeah okay so this is like i'm the
witness i'm right here
so i my mother was very ill
this is going back to 2013 and she was
her health was failing
and i was called to
she was living in north carolina near my
sister my sister was helping take care
of her
and and i got a call and said mike
mom's unconscious they don't expect her
to regain her consciousness so i flew to
north carolina
and i was sitting by my mother's bedside
when she died
it was a really powerful experience that
happened at like three in the morning my
sister and i were up all night
with my mom and we were right there when
she
gave her last breath it was it was a
terribly moving experience for for my
sister and i
and it was it was one that like is is
like it's happened all throughout
mankind's history like children
at the parents bedside when they pass so
the next day like it was three o'clock
in the morning when this happened we had
all these issues we had funeral
arrangements and people to call and
stuff so we were all of us were like
trying to sleep at the same time trying
to get stuff done so that night
i'm at my sister's house my brother was
there too he wasn't at the bedside when
my mom passed but he was there shortly
after we called him
we're sitting in the backyard of my
sister's house she's got like a couch on
the back porch
and her next door neighbor excuse me the
woman who lives across the street ruthie
was right there and she's a real person
you can call her she's like
she's a as powerful a witness as any
person could be this story doesn't have
anything to do with ufos but it has
everything to do with the mystique of
the owl so
ruthie sits across from my sister and i
my sister brother and i am in the middle
on the couch they're right and left me
and they both were very familiar with my
all research
they didn't know what to make of it and
ruthie says you know to me and my
brothers and sisters
my gym gene mike i know
there's an afterlife and i know because
of the experience i had with an owl
and when she said owl both my sister and
brother gave me this look like
did you put her up to this what's going
on like they looked at me like
what's going on here did you and i was
like she looked at my brother and sister
and i had
ruthie ruthie like you don't know what's
going on but i've been doing research
about owls
mystical stuff with owls often
surrounding death i want to hear your
story
so she says when her father died
she was grieving and there's this nature
trail that snakes around the
the neighborhood they live in so she
would walk that nature trail every day
trying to process her grieving
and she every day she would pass this
owl
then one day she was passing out the owl
hooted at her
and she she said i looked at the owl and
she said are you my daddy
and at that moment all her grieving
ended and the owl flew off and she
hasn't seen it since
and she said i know in my heart i know
there is an afterlife
my father came back in the form of an
isle
to help me understand that and to
alleviate my grieving
i have that story that happened to me
and and and i have that story
so many times in the research where
people will say like
often a child will see an owl after
one of their parents has passed and they
will talk to the owl as if it is their
parent
that is normal
and i'm suspecting it's been normal all
throughout human history i'm certain
people stepped out of the cave after
their father died and saw an owl and
talked to the owl as if it was the this
as if it was their dead father i'm not
saying it is i'm not saying it is but
i'm saying that within
the human experience we tap into that
well this ties back to the whole
phenomenon of the synchronicities right
like when you
dedicate so much focus to one thing
it it appears everywhere absolutely just
like the 11 11
or like in my experience that there's a
crazy story
that i that happened crazy thing that
happened to me a long time ago i won't
tell the details
all the details i would bore you with it
but it's there was this girl that we
found swimming in the ocean in
off the cayman islands random girl we
were diving in a boat
with no one boats around us anywhere and
some girls swimming in a dress
got and was in our boat when we came up
from scuba diving
and she was like [ __ ] up on some sort
of drugs we don't know what it was she
was like on mushrooms or something
and she had 242 tattooed on her ankle
and me and my buddy who uh
were diving together we both noticed her
tattoo and now
we see 242 everywhere we go right it's
like a synchronicity it's just like
because we have that crazy experience
that we were both
there we both noticed her tattoo
now me and him i mean almost weekly
we'll text each other these crazy things
where we'll get
a receipt that's 2 42 or we got some
crazy call that was at 2 42.
i feel like this happens with
so many things people that think that
who have had one experience with a
flying saucer or a ufo
they're all now they're always looking
in the sky for the stuff
now now like people who have never had
these experiences
they don't most people aren't
looking into the sky most people are
focusing ahead they're
staring at their phones or they're
driving down the street or they're
staring at a computer screen they don't
have time
to they're they're too involved in the
the rat race
of life they're not looking at the sky
trying to find meaning in something but
people who have had
one experience that kind of jolts them
out of reality
now they're kind of like open to
more of these anything that resembles
that happening again
right that's you right exactly and
that's that's a it seems to be the same
thing with a lot of people who have
these ufo experiences absolutely
yeah so i mean it's funny you go to a
ufo conference you can actually
this is i use that as an example that's
a great way to like you get a bunch of
people in the same room together all of
them are enthusiasts
and i would argue that many of them have
had contact
and are embarrassed to say it oftentimes
so what happens at a ufo conference you
get someone at the bar and you get a few
glasses of wine in them and like what's
going on you know like oftentimes the
really stoic dry researcher
will say like oh you know what i had
this experience and then they'll tell
like
like the experience that sounds like
missing time and right and so
it's so much fun to talk about too and
and you were saying like
going to a ufo conference aren't you
like predisposed to like meeting people
within like yeah that's why you go there
right it's like you go there like the
plumbers go to the plumbers conference
and talk to other plumbers you know so
but the um uh
okay i gotta circle back to where you
were starting me from this the uh
oh the the being predisposed to this
so you can go to a ufo conference and
say ask someone what's your number
and they won't skip a beat and they'll
say 10 10 or they'll say 11
or they'll say one two three four or
they'll say 333. i get a lot of grief
from that
i if i like i've had some powerful like
some of the most powerful
experiences i've had are often
punctuated i'm looking at your watch
right now what time is it
1 12 23. uh okay i was trying to read it
upside down i would have like
proved myself but okay so i tried but um
so
uh the um try me in seven minutes oh
well they're just cheating it doesn't
count
so um so yes you're predisposed
to like have these number things but oh
as far as my own experience one two
three four has shown up a lot
in my in my nuttiness and so it's like
you know like the the time stamp on a
blog post
the you know time stamps on on uh
clocks and things like that so that's i
don't i'm
it's the way i say it i said i'm not
going to start a new religion because i
saw one two three four
but i'm gonna take note of it oftentimes
in the in the book i'll just say
you know i know that the timestamp was
one two three four and i don't wanna
you know i mean i recognize how paranoid
that sounds but
i'm i'm i'm
i mean you're pulling on these little
threads right sometimes the thinnest
little thread
will if you pull on it and find the end
of it it'll it'll
have some deeper meaning